- Hey man, I'm Kevin Smith!
- Jason Mewes!
- And we play Jay and
Silent Bob and that's good
because this movie is called
"Jay and Silent Bob Reboot",
and it's coming out October 15th,
everywhere.
- Yes.
- [Jay] We got three
days to get to Hollywood
and stop this reboot from ever happening.
- Boys, I had a baby.
Jay, brace yourself.
You're about to meet our love child.
- I think I'm gonna need
to see a blood test.
- No, Jay, this is my
daughter Millennium Faulken.
- Can you take us to Hollywood with you?
- No, man, it's a tough ass neighborhood.
- Either you take us to Hollywood
or I stab you both to
death on my own front lawn.
- And on that note, we cue the music.
- I don't think the world needed another
Jay and Silent Bob movie but
we tried to make "Clerks 3"
and it didn't work 'cause
one of the cast members
didn't want to do it.
Then we tried to do "Mallrats
2" and that didn't work
cause Universal didn't want to do it.
And so I was frustrated and I was like
"You know, why are we banging
our heads against the wall".
We own "Jay and Silent Bob".
If I want to play with
my old toys so badly,
why don't we do it with
Jay and Silent Bob?
At least with "Reboot",
I put everything in it.
I kind of encapsulated
my whole career, my life,
his family's in it, his
whole family's in it.
My whole family's in it and stuff.
It's like a big scrapbook of a movie
but it is a gravestone of a movie.
Essentially, look at the movie and like
here lies Kevin Smith,
it gives you everything you need to know
about who he was, when
he was born, when he died
and all that stuff
in-between is the good stuff.
So, once we got the movie
done, then I was like
"All right, I feel better
about life, now I could die",
but I'm still here.
- He's really clever in how he writes
to bring all the movies back.
Like, you know, Jason Lee, you know
reading off the computer just
like Ben did in the last one
but different now instead of the internet.
What's the internet, what's a Comic-Con,
it's, spoilers. (laughs)
- You keep giving away the movie, man.
- Sorry, sorry!
It's super clever I feel.
- Where were you?
We could have used that on the poster.
"Super clever, Jay Mewes".
- Exact.
- "Super clever, the guy in the movie".
(upbeat music)
- Do I show them?
- Yeah.
Pa-pazin!
"Batman V Superman".
- Honestly, I've watched
this movie 30 times now
and I watch it every time,
you know my wife's like
"Why you still watching that movie?"
'Cause I'm gonna love it one day.
Should it have been made?
Let's go to you.
- I feel like any movie, with one, for me
- Be careful, the internet
is listening and they're all
just sitting there waiting
to drag you, be careful.
- It's something that
I've always wanted to see.
Not necessarily that, but I always say
"Hey, who could win in a fight?
"The Thing from Fantastic
Four or The Hulk?".
Or Superman, Batman,
Superman, so for me to
get a ver, a V in there,
I feel like, I was happy it was made.
Not necessarily that movie--
- You were waiting for
that V your whole life.
- Yes, exactly.
- Like, put a V in every title, man.
- That's it, I'm happy they made a V.
Maybe not that movie, but
I'm happy they made a V.
- More V's for you.
- V.
- Batman, Batman, they
are rebooting Batman.
- Yes.
- And the boy from Twilight
is gonna be Batman now.
He's gonna sparkle like
a vampire in Twilight.
No, he's a genius actor
this kid, Rob Pattinson.
He's gonna do a great job as Batman
and you should be happy.
They're not getting some
like roided out dude
to play Batman, they're getting
little skinny kid like you.
That means you could be next for Batman.
- Never.
- Yeah, you don't need
no muscles to be Batman.
- Well, I don't know--
- We'll go back to Michael Keaton,
remember Michael Keaton
didn't have no muscles.
- I don't think any of them did.
- Affleck's got muscles.
When he holds you, you feel held.
- Well.
- Batman, Matt Reeves's
Batman, you on board?
Got Jonah Hill as either "The
Penguin" or "The Riddler"
we're not sure, maybe a
combination of both? "The Peddler"?
- What?
- "The Renguin".
- No way.
- Nah, I don't know.
But they are saying it's
one of those two roles.
- I love it, I'm always
down for new movies
that involve superheroes
and/or crime fighters.
- Co-signed, do it Matt Reeves.
- Back to the Future.
No way.
- Never, never in a million years.
- Indiana Jones, never.
- Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let's have a discussion.
- Fair enough.
- What kind of reboot
are we talking about?
- Don't talk to me, I say no.
- No!?
- No, yeah no way.
- He's a great character.
- He is, but.
- Who's your favorite actor,
you love Vincent D'Onofrio.
- Yes.
- You love Vincent D'Onofrio.
- Love him.
- What's this, one of the
crime shows you watch him on?
- Law & Order: Criminal Intent.
- All right, and you loved him as Kingpin.
- Oh, he's amazing.
- Okay, Steven Spielberg goes
"We're doing Indiana Jones again
and this time it's Vincent D'Onofrio.
- Okay.
- You in?
- Do I watch it, sure.
- Well there you go.
- Okay.
- Look how easily I flipped you.
- But, we're asking--
- You got to stick to your things,
be like "Nah, I don't even care
if it's Vincent D'Onofrio".
- But I don't think they should,
I don't think they
should do it, I'm saying.
- They totally should.
- I think they should add, if anything--
- They should wait 10 years,
maybe after Harrison Ford has passed away,
which hopefully will
be 100 years from now,
then they do it.
- Or they, yeah, all
right, that makes sense.
- But that's a character,
oh, we revealed this one.
But that's a character
that they haven't like,
he's an architect, you'd get away
with somebody else doing it.
- I think they should add
it, like Star Wars almost.
- They tried, and then
Shia LaBeouf was in it
and people were like "Oh no!".
- You're right, oh my gosh,
how'd I'd mixed that up.
- Which is crazy cause Shia
LaBeouf really good in stuff
but you know, they had him
swinging on trees in the movie.
- I don't know, I'm
making this up as I go.
- You're getting good at that.
- "The Mummy".
- Is The Mummy better cause
Tom Cruise met the Mummy?
- Do I think--
- Was it an okay world where all
the mummies had never met Tom Cruise?
- See, I think way--
- They made a bunch of "Mummy's".
- I think they didn't
need to make that "Mummy"
because the old ones were awesome.
- Hold on, what are the old ones to you?
- The old ones are, what do
you mean what are they to me?
- When you say "the old ones",
what "Mummy" movies are old to you?
- There's three with Brendan Fraser.
- Okay, are those the old
ones you're talking about?
- Yes.
- Cause there's even older ones than that.
Black and white "Mummy" movies--
- Oh, bring it back!
- So even Brendan Fraser
who you're about to suck off
and be like "what a hero is",
they rebooted that movie so--
- Fair enough.
- You gotta go way
back, so the question is
should anybody have ever touched The Mummy
after they did "The Mummy" the first time.
- Ah, yes.
- Way back in the days of
Universal monsters, really?
- Because I didn't know
about the old "Mummy's"
so for me personally, I
needed the new "Mummy"
with Brendan Fraser.
- Out of the mouths of
babes another vermin,
that's exactly why reboots are okay.
Cause he was never gonna
watch the black and white one.
- Well, I didn't know they existed--
- He don't like black and white movies
even though we were in one.
- A lot of people know the name Tom Cruise
so it's like, I feel like, you know--
- That's a hot take right
there internet, you hear that?
"A lot of people know
the name Tom Cruise".
- Yes.
- Fight me, hold my beer.
- What was his catchphrase?
- Tom Cruise?
- Yeah.
- Tom Cruise's catchphrase?
- I'm rich!
I don't remember what--
- Didn't he, wasn't it him
who jumped on the couch
and said something crazy?
- He did, but he didn't
have a catchphrase.
He wasn't like "Snooch to
the Nooch", that's you!
- But I was thinking--
- You're thinking of yourself.
- No, I was thinking of
Charlie Sheen's catchphrase
which was--
- Winning!
Did you just literally confuse Tom Cruise
with Charlie Sheen?
Charlie Sheen feeling great,
Tom Cruise going "I got a lot
of work ahead of me still,
I need a better publicist".
What!?
- Yes!
- "Big Trouble in Little China".
- I don't know if it's possible,
but I would like to
see how that turns out.
- I'm gonna cut your throat right here.
- Why?
- This is a sacrilege
to remake this movie.
- I just said I don't
know if it's possible!
- This is a visionary movie,
driven by personality.
Key man clause, I would say.
You can't remake movies where
there's a key man involved.
Key man in this is John Carpenter,
unless John Carpenter's
rebooting this movie,
I'm gonna, you know, I'll
see it, I see everything
but I'm mad about it!
That's for damn sure, just
like the rest of the internet.
- I just said, I don't think it's possible
but I'd like to see how it turns out.
- Why not make it a requel right?
Where it's like--
- Why not make it an animated movie.
- Shut up.
A requel, then you get Kurt Russell in it,
he's back and then you hand off the reigns
to someone younger,
like "Star Trek" style.
Get J.J. for this, then I'm there man,
but other than that, John Carpenter.
You need John Carpenter,
he is "Big Trouble in Little China".
Two key figures in that movie,
John Carpenter, Kurt Russel.
If you aint got either, you got this.
- Princess Bride.
No André the Giant, never.
- I got to tell you, I'm
shocked he even knew the movie.
I'm shocked he pulled André
the Giant, I'm so proud of you.
- Thank you.
- I'm so proud of you, and
you're absolutely right.
Without André, look,
never, even without André
there's no, but somebody
said to me the other day
cause I was like "No,
never!" And they're like
"What if they did a Dread
Pirate Roberts movie?",
where it's just about like the many dudes
who have been the "Dread Pirate Roberts"
and then I was like "Well,
I'd watch that", you know.
So maybe there's a way to
do it, don't reboot it,
you can't tell "The
Princess Bride" story again.
That's a singular moment in time,
that's like remaking "Clerks",
don't do that unless you call us,
and then keep us involved.
- Do you feel like they
should redo the "Blade"?
- They are redoing "Blade".
- Without Wesley Snipes.
- They are redoing, well,
I don't know that it will be without.
Maybe they'll find a way to work him in,
if Wesley wants to be involved,
but it won't be played
by Wesley this time.
It will be Mahershala Ali.
- Oh.
- Yeah, he's coming back as "Blade".
- Oh, I like it.
- He's gonna be "Blade".
- Oh no.
- Spin it around.
- Dun dun dun.
- Now, they have rebooted this.
The original series had a bunch of sequels
but then they rebooted it with
another guy fairly recently,
and they took all the humor out of it.
- Yeah, I don't--
- Like the first one was
kind of satirical and stuff
"I'll buy that for a dollar!".
The reboot was just like,
they're like for reals man,
this cop is dead and now he's a robot, yo.
Like it was very, very serious.
Would you ever reboot "RoboCop"?
- No.
- Why?
- Because, I don't know.
- What if they gonna write you a check?
You didn't even ask how much!
You didn't ask any of
the pertinent questions.
- Oh!
Say it three times.
- Candyman.
- Two more times--
- One more time.
- Candyman.
- Bullshit, bunch of bullshit.
They're redoing this.
They can redo this, I have no
skin in the "Candyman" game
where I'm like "What! That's a sacrilege".
It feels like you could totally redo this.
In a world where they like
did a thousand "Halloween's",
then disavowed most of them, be like
"Now the new ones are good",
they could totally get away--
- Was it done by Tony Todd?
Tony Todd did the first one?
Was that who did it?
- He was in it, he didn't
do it but he was the guy--
- I mean, sorry, he was the
guy who played "Candyman".
- And he could totally come back--
- He could.
- Or play another role in
it or something like that.
- I see him as, "Tony Todd is Back".
- You want, but then it's not a reboot.
Then it's a sequel.
- Is it?
- If it's Tony Todd,
it's kind of a sequel.
- Even if everything else is different?
- Well, it could be a requel
which is a sequel with a reboot kind of--
- Oh, right--
- Inside, they shove it inside.
- Oh, okay.
- "Star Trek".
- Should they reboot
"Star Trek", they have!
- "Star Trek".
- J.J. did it, did a really great job.
- Yes.
- Yeah, I like the new "Star Trek",
the old "Star Trek" I enjoy as well,
but a lot of thinking.
A lot of sitting around and talking,
that's kind of like "Clerks" and stuff.
J.J.'s "Star Trek" is like "Run Spock!",
like everybody's in a hurry and stuff.
- And they have the technology now.
- Yeah they can rebuild--
- For space.
- Better, stronger, faster.
- For space, ships.
- Well, the first one
went to space as well.
- But I'm saying now, they can
like actually make things--
- Make it look better.
Like "That is the Final Frontier!".
You didn't believe it when it was on TV?
You're like "That aint
space, it's a TV show,
and that aint no Tribble".
- Well, it was like tin
foil, and stuff like that.
Now, it's like full on, you know.
- Gene Roddenberry
rolling over in his grave
hearing you say tin foil.
Crapping on an American icon.
- Duck tape and tin foil!
- Oh my God!
- "Po-poison!"
- Whoa, whoa.
- Now what?
- Let me tell you something.
- Well, here, let's discuss it.
- All right, let's do it.
- I think I could go
with this, here's why.
You know, number one.
Those are just two kids.
- Yes.
- There's a convenience store,
they have turnover and
employees all the time.
You get all sorts of
clerks behind the counter.
Number two, we're gonna
get a little taste,
and do none of the work.
None of the work!
And, if the movie's good,
we'll get like credit
even though we didn't do anything.
- Oh, I like it.
- Yeah, work smarter not harder.
That's what I say.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Let me tell ya, if my kid got older
and wanted to reboot the movie,
that would be the best case scenario
because then I could
like shadow direct it.
- Oh yeah.
- From the sides and
stuff cause I'm her dad
I'm like "Oh no!", and stuff like that.
- Yeah, yeah, no.
- No, that'd be awesome,
like, that, how sweet.
I hope to Lord, the Lord!
That my kid gets the idea.
I should start planting that idea.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'd be like "You should reboot Clerks".
- You should watch this episode.
- Yeah, what episode?
- What we're doing now.
- Oh this!? Yeah.
I'm like "Hey, you should watch
this thing on the internet"
and she's like "Is it you
and your friend again?
"No way dad".
I'm like "Come on, this
one's interesting".
That could be our thing, man.
Like the Smith thing, like how
Philip Morris has cigarettes.
We just have "Clerks" for the
rest of all time and stuff,
and people are like
"Why are we still
watching this B.S. movie".
- Never forgotten.
- Yeah, never.
We could be in them too, we
get little cameos and stuff.
As old men that come in
the store and be like--
- (stutters)
- You could come in and be
like "Hey, where's the mall?"
and the audience would be like (claps).
Who else would you want
in a "Clerks" reboot?
- Playing Dante would be--
- Right now, I'd say, do
you ever watch "Fleabag"?
- Mm mm.
- What's her name, Phoebe Waller-Bridge?
She's, that "Fleabag" is so good dude.
I watched it before the Emmy's
so don't accuse me of being a bandwagon.
- No, I--
- That was big-time.
I say, let her play both clerks.
- All right and I say Thanos,
the guy who plays Thanos.
- Oh wait--
- And Vincent D'Onofrio--
- The guy who plays
Thanos or Thanos himself.
- No, the guy who plays Thanos.
- So, Josh Brolin.
- He is--
- Cause I really want to see the version
of "Clerks" where Thanos is working there.
Just because they serve you
doesn't mean they (snaps)
and everyone disappears and stuff.
- We shouldn't have done that (snaps).
- Listen to the editor.